[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
research infrastructures and genomics
how cutter precision medicine institute
qatar genome program is building the
next generation of infrastructures to
test the value of predictive genomics
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
raja masai baji operations manager
cutter genome program cutter foundation
cutter raja you may now begin your
presentation
hello everybody thank you for the
introduction
and i am happy today to present to you
qatar genome program
from the
its inception to
worry where we are today
basically qatar genome
started with a
strategy and a vision at a very high
level of leadership in qatar in 2013.
the first genome was sequel sequenced in
2015
and today in 2025 we are hoping to reach
the population scale genetic test
testing whether using whole genome
sequencing or genotyping technologies
qatar genome at its first stage was
incubated in qatar biobank so cattle
biobank it's a national program
to study
the environmental or genetic
contribution
of
disease burden in qatar
so the qatar genome started with
sequestering the qatar biobank cohort
and the advantage of qatar biobanker is
that is linked and integrated to rich
phenotypic data that is collected during
the three hours visit in qatar biobank
ranging from 66 blood markers to full
mri body scan
spirometry exercise test
height and weight blood pressure etc
also the qatar biobank is integrated
with the electronic medical record
so we receive
in a regular basis updates from the
electronic medical records of the
participants so we can follow up their
health status
so so far we have sequenced 28 thousands
of qatari citizens and four thousands of
arab
samples
so what with what is unique about qatar
genome program is its location so qatar
is
an underrepresented population in the
genetic studies so it's a small country
in the middle east
there is a high number of expatriate
community especially from
south asia and arab
countries and qatar has amongst the
highest
consanguinity rate in the world the
second actually would make it very
interesting for genetic studies
what is also unique about qatar genome
program is the
the centralized healthcare system which
allow us to integrate the electronic
medical record throughout the country
with qatar biobank and qatar genome data
also the program doesn't focus on
genomic data only but for uh that has a
multi-omics approach
so a number of our samples has
translictomics data proteomics
metabolomics epigenomics and
microbiomics
making the research utility of the data
higher and higher for more uh
for more studies
we we have also in qatar state of the
art infrastructure that is offered to
the research community for free in order
to mine the data
so although we are working in qatar
actually we are exposed to a big number
of countries just because of the
uniqueness of the qatari population
so there is a big uh a big expat
community from arab countries
that is actually representing over 400
to 500 million people uh what we we call
the arab world
these populations are among the ancient
populations
they are all within the qatar expat
community and they are largely
underrepresented in the literature so we
are really feeling a gap here
in terms of international genetic
research
in in the qatar genome program we are
focusing on the whole spectrum of
genetic disease from monogenic or single
gene disorders because of a high
concentrity rate in the population
also to a polygenic disorders because of
the high prevalence of common disease
like diabetes and cardiovascular so we
are hoping to build a platform for
discovery for the full spectrum of
genetic diseases
catara genome program has been
recognized as one of the programs that
will expand the diversity in genomics
and as you can see on the screen this is
a nature paper listing the catal genome
among the most important programs in the
world expanding the diversity
the qatar genome program
national strategy
is based on seven building blocks
first of all is the national biobanking
so when they started the genome they
incubated the cattle genome in qatar
biobank because it was well established
with a big number of samples the
community
knows very well the project that it was
easy
to expose the community to the genetic
research
among this capability we have built a
big genomics infrastructure with our
partners and we also hired a big human
capacity from bioinformaticians genetic
counselor geneticist in order to mind
the data bear in mind that qatar
is a i would say a young country and
everything was has to be built from
scratch
for that we had to prepare also all the
regulatory environments
to make this research possible by
building or offering policies and
regulations for genomic research
research we have also gathered many
researchers from the country and from
abroad to mine the data and to
investigate key questions
in terms of genetic
of course now we are moving towards
clinical implementation and i will show
you today some early results of the
program that show the utility of the
clinical implementation of the findings
of course
all of this in the hope of building a
big data hub where all the data is
integrated
in a way that makes the discovery
meaningful
and possible
sorry
so in terms of policies and regulation
it was very important to build
the ethical
the ethical environment of
genomic research knowing that qatar has
an islamic background
a group of islamic scholars has to work
together to make the debate to make a
public debate about genetic research in
the country
and these are examples of the documents
that can be found in the public domain
that regulate the genomic research in
the country
education was also a very important
component of the program but we didn't
want to focus on the postgraduate or the
health professional
education we started to educate
a very young kids because we know these
are the future generation and this is
really to uh to prepare the future
generation uh to embrace uh genetics
because we believe that this will be the
common in the coming years
so we have programs early school years
where we have a comic series that you
can see on the screen
for kids to uh to explain uh in a
lucrative and in
a simple way some key genomic or genetic
concepts
and we also have a dna museum where uh
stud
small children can have a tour
and we can
we we can raise their curiosity around
genetics
we have also middle and high school
programs where the national education
program has been changed to include
some key concepts of genomics i say
genomics not genetics so it's really to
prepare
the young students for future science
careers and of course we have
in partnership with local universities
graduate and postgraduate programs
around genetic counseling and precision
medicine
we also we also offer internship
programs and scholarships
for master's degrees and ph and phd
programs
so so we are doing this in the hope of
um
of fostering uh the genomic research in
the country by building an ecosystem
uh that allow uh the researchers
and
also the the public
to
to have
an honest and transparent debate about
genetics
the genomic research of course needs the
data and this is what we we are
collecting and what we are doing in the
program but also need a big
infrastructure uh to mine the data and
we have built a big data center uh that
that is offered for free
for the researchers to mine the data
as alaka said we are enrolling students
in master and phd program through our
local university partners
and they are also offered to analyze the
data
we have also funding schemas
to fund research
on genetics and on personalized medicine
this funding schema is called path
towards personalized medicine uh this
happens uh on a yearly basis
and recently also we have created a data
federation sharing model where we offer
genetic sequencing or genotyping to
researchers that they want to
collaborate with our program but they
have to establish
a broad consent
to recruit participants that allow
their future use of the research of the
data for future research programs
and
we
we are partner
with the researchers to
establish a data governance program that
respects the consent of of course of the
research subjects but also
that can offer the data for future
research purposes
so now i'm gonna uh i'm gonna
show you some early results of the
program which show clearly
uh why it is important to establish
these national programs
so first we have uh we have studied
around um
45
clinically relevant traits basically
blood biomarkers and the height and the
bmi
and actually we
we have found million of novel variants
that are not previously reported
in the literatures with thousands of
novel signals
so this show clearly the importance of
such studies to establish to establish
pollution acrylic scores that are
specific to our population and in this
paper uh dr omar elba who is the lead pi
and dr carsten show clearly that
the polygenic scores that are calculated
in um
in european descendant
population
doesn't
work well with our population and it is
clearly needed uh to have more studies
uh uh more jiva studies on our
population
here also
i you can see
um a paper from one of the lead pi of
our research consortium
his name is eunice mcrobb dr eunice
macrob and his team have showed that
the qgp data has a particular data
structure that is not found in other
population and you can see
here
in very simple terms the callers are
quite different from uh from the other
population showing that uh it's clear
that the the qatari population has a
unique structure that was not seen in uh
in the previous studies
we are really feeling a gap here
regarding the scmt scmg genes
we have also studied the prevalence of
uh
disease uh or for risk mutations in the
scmg genes that are really interesting
in terms of return of genetic results to
the to the our research participants
so basically 2.3 of the qgp sequence
participants are carrier of a pathogenic
or likely pathogenic variants in one of
the 59 scm cmg genes
and we have also identified 60
pathogenic and likely pathogenic
variants in 25 smg genes that are
specific to to our population
so this paper shows clearly uh that it's
really important to establish uh models
of returning
interest and results to the participants
which can um
contribute to the prevent preventative
medicine implementation of preventative
medicine in qatar
so another another a very interesting
paper from the qatar genome research
consortium is the cancer
risk landscape
in the qgp data set
and the early results shows that three
point seventeen percent
of qatar genome data dataset is a
carrier of a rare cancer risk variant
and
and also again here
this emphasizes the importance of these
type of studies but also the importance
of
establishing models of returning results
another paper from the research
consortium
about pharmacogenomics landscape shows
that
the qatari population
is carrier of 3.6 in average every
qatari is a carrier of 3.6 actionable
genotype or diplotype
mutation affecting 13 drugs with
guidelines and
99.5 percent almost everybody is at
least a carrier of one clinically
actionable genotype in terms of
pharmacogenomic
for simvastatin for example which is
highly used it's one of the mostly used
drugs in the country because of the high
cholesterol level
um
the the risk of carrying
a variant that increases the risk of
myopathy is uh um is more than 32
so
so basically here you can see that
our
our program on our research consortium
is clearly feeling a big gap
in terms of middle eastern
genomics
and here we also have more papers uh in
the pipeline uh studying the loss of
function variants the mendelian diseases
the hla the care and rbc genotypes and
the herbs and
exogenous infectious disease
agents in the genome so we hope that
these papers will be published very very
soon and and will contribute more
to establish
clear a clear strategy for
precision medicine implementation
also so we were hit by covered like
everybody else and we were able because
of the availability of the data we were
able to also to participate as qatar
genome
to the to the big international
consortium the the host genome
initiative and actually qatar was the
only member from outside europe usa and
the far east in addition to brazil
so qatar contributed with its data to
understand the contribution of the
host's genome in into the civility of
the covet 19.
so now
with these interesting findings the
leadership have understood that there is
a clear
interest in moving from population
genomics to more clinical implementation
so it's normal that we have we went
through a big
phase for establishing the platform and
the infrastructure uh educating
the community about the importance of
genetic in order to enroll them in this
genetic
program and then to
provide researchers with time to mine
the data and to understand how
how different
or um
what is the potential of this data in
terms of genetic
now because it is clearly found uh that
uh this
that the the population will benefit
directly from
this genetic testing
we are moving towards clinical
implementation
so
for that we are establishing
the qatar precision medicine institute
so we are we
we are still we will be uh um again
we will be named qatar genome but we are
now clearly merging with qatar biobank
to
become qatar precision medicine
institute
and now the focus will be more on
disease cohorts
so it is really to increase the their
clinical utility of the cohort and to
focus on a specific prevalent diseases
in the country
but also we want to see models of
integration of genetic into healthcare
the focal point for precision
precision medicine related activities is
to continue to use the biobank facility
but to offer the facility for the
national level
is to bank all the samples that are
related
to
disease or population cohorts
to build a big uh a big capacity in
terms of bioinformatics and clinical
bioinformatics to standardize the
operations and to get the accreditations
to to have a national data management
and governance
strategy to make the data sharing and
the data federation possible
for the uh
in the whole country
and but also
is really to establish what we call the
clinical genomes
this is all related to the
accreditations and to the to the
regulation and we know that it's not
always easy uh uh to um
to marry research and clinical
implementation
of course we need to focus on education
now education of healthcare
professionals to uh
to introduce
introduce them to the notion of
precision medicine and use of genetic
because this can be disruptive to their
clinical activity so big education
activity is needed there and also we are
hoping that precision medicine uh can
create an
innovation ecosystem in the country and
see some startup companies uh um
raising here and in the country around
this uh
this thematic
so the approach we we have taken is to
start with pilots so we are identifying
low-hanging fruits
to show the utility of uh clinical
implementation
and we have used the early results of
the project
to show a
quickly impact and
this is really to gain uh the the trust
of the clinicians and the commun
community and the leadership to continue
uh on a wider level
afterwards
so the first pilot we are we are
starting at qatar biobank so we
we will preemptively genotype
qatar biobank
participants and provide them
with a
starting
related
statin myopathy related risk
so basically uh if a biobank
participants come
to the to the biobank and he is a
statistic native but his
uh
blood pressure or his cholesterol level
uh um
[Music]
has he has a recommendation to take
statin he will be referred uh to hamad
medical corporation which is the health
care provider here in the country
he will be prescribed with statin but
with uh this uh referral the healthcare
provider will receive a pharmacogenomic
report
that will show if the participant
has the risk variant or no and what are
the recommendation of course this
healthcare healthcare providers are
educated
to act upon this data and we want to see
what would be the clinical utility and
the clinical validity of such approach
the second pilot is about the
clopidogrel and now because clopidogrel
needs
a quick
a quick action we are investigation
investigating the adoption of rapid
point of care reactive testing to guide
crypto degree therapy
so what will we will install uh
point-of-care
genotyping devices
in few clinics and we will try to
establish
pipelines to guide
the clopadryl prescriptions based on
genetic data
the next
pilot is about breast cancer
chemotherapy
and and actually we were approached by
clinicians because there is high uh
variability of outcomes reported amongst
patients treated with the same
chemotherapy chemotherapy regimens
and here the the objective is really to
study uh what is what are the reason
reasons of this variability and what is
the contribution of genetics uh there
so it's not always about clinical
implementation and sometimes we need to
focus on specific questions and make a
discovery that may be proper to this
population
in terms of disease risk we are
we started the pilot for returning uh
carrier
uh results of brakaman and brakatu in
collaboration with again hamad medical
corporation which is the healthcare
provider here and basically we are using
the genetic data coming from research
pipeline
and anyone who is carrier is consented
to receive a genetic
feedback if the the participants can
sense
consent they will be uh
for um referred to hamad medical
corporation for confirmatory testing for
further assessments of family history
and then if they are positive they will
be enrolled
in the
breast cancer screening program so
basically here the the the objective is
really uh to screen a big a
a big lar a
big number of the population for
bracawan and bracket to screen in and um
and all and detect the high risk
individuals and then enroll them in in
the breast
breast cancer screen and national
program
now with the the primary health care we
have also pilots
on returning
genomic reports for
for wellness and lifestyle so basically
the primary health care center has a
program called the wellness program
these are programs that
that aim to
to follow
some patients that are
obese
or
pre-diabetic
to change their lifestyle
to put them in a special diet regimen
and exercise in the hope of
of reverting back uh the their their
status of obesity or diabetes now what
we want to investigate is the
is if
if these participants receive um genomic
report about the risk of
being obese of or developing
diabetes would that genetic information
increase their motivation
to
follow a healthy lifestyle
and the second project is
is to
investigate the willingness of
primary health care patients to enroll
in genetic studies and this is the phdc
smart health check so the phcc smart
health check program is a big
a big national program uh for screening
for common diseases and actually now we
have uh um
we have in the pa we are in a pilot
study to include uh genetics as well so
these participants will be offered to
consent for genetic testing to
contribute for research and then uh we
are also establishing models for
returning interest in genetic
findings to these participants
so now i would like to
here to show you the contribution of
thermo fisher technology to our project
so
basically a cattle genome program is
based on whole genome sequencing and the
reason for that is that as i showed
previously this is an underrepresented
population and we we didn't know the
frequency
of uh
of the variance what is the landscape of
genetic diseases and common diseases in
the country
now that we sequenced 20 80 000 whole
genome and we have and we have early
results we we have a better
understanding of the prevalence of
disease or pathogenic pathogenic
variants
in the country and the most important
variants to be used in disease risk
prediction
and all these variants have been put in
an array which is in its its second
version now called the q-chip
so the uh q-chip is a cutter-specific
snip microarray that is uh mainly used
for the genetic testing of known
variants that affect health
so it provides information about the
carrier status of no one gene variants
inheritable conditions
uh like breast cancer for example
it also has a pharmacogenomic molders
for the variants that that will uh will
require alternative drug dosing or
alternate an alternative
drug
and it has
also
more information that are specific to
the qatari population so we have almost
20 80
to 28 000 qatari specific variants that
are predicted to be pathogenic and that
are unique to our population
this array is cap accredited and
this is a big advantage for clinical
implementation
following the q chip we have worked also
on what we call the pan arab array the
pan arab array is a whole now genome
genotyping array so the q-chip is more
about red variants
whereas the pan-arab array is more about
common variants
and the the pan-arab array
actually was
was designed is under design sorry it's
under design with thermo fisher uh and
we are using for that an arab reference
panel of more than 2 400
arab genomes coming from 19 countries
and what we are hoping here is to offer
this span arab
array which which which is which is
considered as a cost effective tool for
whole genome sequencing to the arab
world and make the the genomic genetic
profiling of a large number of arabs
possible
and if we combine this
this genetic data
with their medical records or that or
some kind of clinical information we
think that we will empower the region uh
with uh with an important precision
medicine tool uh for discovery
of this uh uh for discovery and
establishment of disease prediction
models that are specific to this
understudied population
so what we we
now what we see the q-tip plus the
pan-arab array as a real
an army swiss
uh knife
and swiss uh sorry swiss army knife that
can be
used as a precision medicine discovery
and application platform
so with one test that is done once in
life
we can
do a carrier screening we can do
diagnosis we can do disease risk
prediction we can offer a platform for
genomic profiling of a large number of
population we can offer also
pharmacogenomic implementation we can
foster
research and we can of course create and
then apply polygenic risk scores so this
is really a big opportunity for the
arab arab world
that was made possible
by a qatar genome program
so following this work it was very
important for us to understand uh the
acceptability or the willingness of the
population to continue or to contribute
to contribute to the to the genome
program especially that we are going now
to the population phase
and
we have established two surveys one with
the public one with the healthcare
professional
and
the good news is that we have the
support of both so here i will i will
show you
uh the results of um
of the uh these are the key results of
these surveys
so basically with the general population
eighty percent either strongly agree or
agree
that um
they want to know about about their
genetic makeup
and this can be also sensed from the
consenting level
of people here for genomic research but
also for the returning for the ris
for receiving
genetic results from their research data
also
people here they are willing to
participate
they they want to contribute
to genomic programs
and
they think that the
they want to see how qgp is relevant to
their to their life and how it can help
them so basically here the participants
they want to see something in return
so it's
and that's why it was very important for
us to establish these models of
returning genomic results because it's
clearly that this is what people are
looking for
also a professional
health professional support qgp plans so
basically almost 97 percent is either
they agree or
slightly or agree uh strongly
that the national genome programs will
help implement precision medicine and it
will improve health care
and also health professional they are
willing to invest time in training
which is
again what we can see also in our
program whenever we offer uh educational
program we have a big
number of uh
of applications uh so people that are
really interested to understand more
so what i hope here that i gave you an
overview of what we are doing and where
we are going
to
and and and i would like to thank uh all
the people that are behind this work so
the qgp the cathar genome program team
but also qatar biobank
which is a pillar in this program
qatar foundation
sidra hospital and hamer america
corporation qatar university and hamad
bin khalifa university and the qatar
national
research funding
funding program here
so thank you again and here i can show
i'm showing you two pictures of qatar
like in
1960
and qatar today and you can see that
this country is booming uh we are doing
everything uh from scratch but uh it's
the speed of of how things are happening
here
is is amazing thank you all and
i'm happy to have your quest to answer
your questions
thank you raja for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started
our first question is
qatar genome is an integral part of an
ecosystem of life science and medical
research infrastructures working in
symbiosis
please talk about the challenges you
faced to create such an environment what
are the lessons learned that you think
could help researchers in other
countries achieve similar collaborations
thank you that's very uh good question
so uh the challenges that we have faced
as i said during my presentation is
really have to build everything from
scratch is really to build uh the
expertise uh to build the infrastructure
uh the strategy
uh the regulation all at the same time
so it was really a lot to do
and um
the thing that helped us a lot is to
really have connection at the very early
stage with key national programs in
other countries this is really what
allowed us to
learn from others
and to avoid the mistakes maybe that
were unfortunately
faced
with other
genome programs
and now i think what was a very
important lesson learned is that it's
very important to have
a very high level
leadership support
so politicians are very important
in national programs
and
you can see that in other countries as
well we always
connect
a genome program to a political figure
and i think this is very important
because we need the support of different
ministries
genome program is interlinked with with
different
different stakeholders
so without the leadership support it's
very hard to cascade the decisions of
the strategies to operational level
and also what is important i think is
really to when it's our in our case we
we are
relying on a network of stakeholders
it's very important to involve us
involve them from the beginning
even at the
strategy
establishment level
but also
it's very important to give credit to
everybody so qatar the thank you slides
the slide that you've seen at the end is
very important qatar genome program is
about a big network and we we really
want to thank everybody because without
them
all of this wouldn't have been possible
thank you
thank you our next question is let's
talk about the qatari array the famous
q-chip which is helping to drive much of
the research you showed us today
we know it is even being exposed in the
qatar national museum why did you choose
microarray technology
over wgs and lps what are the advantages
you have experienced in the lab
okay so
now for us we didn't really choose uh
the genotyping over the whole genome
sequencing it's really we see that as a
complementary technology
it was very important for us to do whole
genome sequencing as a discovery
platform because as i said this is an
underrepresented population
now the the genotyping technology came
after because we thought that and now we
know enough
about the genetic landscape of the
country and we were able to identify key
variants that can be
put on the array
now what is very interesting about the
array is the scalability and the cost
effectiveness
when it comes to uh to scalability i
think the arrays are
is the best tool because if you can do
100 in whole genome you can do 1000 in
in in in arrays
so
scalability cost effectiveness
uh but also the downstream complexity of
the analysis so it's way easier to get
accreditation uh
when we use arrays
establishing standardized pipelines was
way easier for us
using array data compared to whole
genome data so it's it really depends on
what we we want to do some for some of
us for some of our projects we are still
uh using whole genome sequencing but for
uh clinical implementation we are more
shifting towards genotyping technologies
hey thank you
next question
what were the factors that led you to
choose thermo fisher scientific as a
partner for the qgp
uh we have experience with the uh with
illumina technology and thermo fisher
but we have chosen thermo fisher because
of the quality of the data so
we we were able to see that thermo
fisher is a platform that
provide
high quality
data so
we were happy with that
and but also we were happy with the
relationship with thermo fisher so it
it went beyond just the commercial
relationship we have established an r d
relationship so they were really helping
in this
journey of discovery
um
designing props that are specific to
capture some rare variants in our
population so this is really what
made it a natural choice for us
is uh is because we know uh we know the
technology uh we know the quality of the
data but also the specific relationship
that we have uh with the with the design
team
all right great thank you and it looks
like we have time for one more question
the pan-arab array promises to bring
innovation in genomics to the whole arab
community
what are your expectations for this
project so our expectation of is really
to build large arab consortia
is to make this array a platform that
will allow
countries that probably cannot afford
whole genome sequencing big genomic
platform
to profile a big number of population
but also to build a network in the arab
countries
and to integrate this data and
to build a network of expertise to mine
such data and to build uh really
precision medicine tools that are
specific to the to this population so we
really hope that we are go that we will
use this tool
uh to make connections and to make big
projects uh possible
great well thank you raja for do you
have any final comments for our audience
um i just want to thank you uh for the
the invitation and um and thank you for
the questions that are uh very relevant
and i'm happy to answer any question
that may come afterwards
thank you
thank you again raja for your time today
in your presentation
thank you
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
thank you bye-bye bye
you